I saw an article the other day that the
BBC want to make sure that one out of
seven headline TV presenters is gay or
lesbian which made me wonder why they
want to reduce the number of gay to be
honest right so they've got this
I attended it seems like to me in hiring
this positive discrimination in favor of
certain ethnic minorities and that seems
to me now in the world that we live in
to be part of a particular mindset that
isn't just something that people do just
because that seems to be a reflection of
a particular view do you think those
things are connected I do and you know
the diversity agenda so-called always
amuses me in in interests in in regard
to the BBC because okay I'd like to see
diversity at the BBC I really would I
think it would be a huge advance if we
had proper diversity at the BBC some
political diversity for instance and
maybe some diversity from the current
monoculture of social liberalism and a
few social conservatives that would be a
kind of diversity would it not I mean
the fact is that simply having a color
chart you know color code chart and
making sure you've got every you know
the right proportion of everyone from
from black to albino and everything in
between and guarantee is nothing about
the fairness of the outer of the output
all it means is that you have window
dressed the screen in some way which is
thought to reflect modern Britain
without doing anything to seriously
consider the content of what you're
broadcasting which is surely the
important thing you know there is no
diversity in the BBC in that day in
there in that sense they are all social
liberals as I really know as we started
talking about Andrew Neil the great
right-wing yeah he's a social liberal
there are no social conservatives at the
BBC Robin wants his job back
[Laughter]
the BBC I reckon there's somebody who
discusses the office we have no Alby
knows this needs to change they want
that guy from The DaVinci Code but you
see this a lot in comedy and this is one
of my bugbears
the majority of people in the referendum
voted brexit there is only one Pro
brexit comedian on the BBC it's Jeff and
Olcott we love you Jeff you're brilliant
there should be other comedians of
course why is there not any more
well right-wing isn't funny I just have
to say that because that's what people
say as if as if being on different sides
of the political spectrum somehow
effects how funny you are
it's ridiculous welter I mean oh you
know there yeah so why is that
okay let's it's a very interesting
question you know I've often I often
wondered why it was that Jeremy Hardy
r.i.p bless him who I didn't find funny
at all I thought he was merely a
propagandist and you could not imagine
someone the obverse of Jeremy Hardy on
the right ever being given a platform by
the BBC it just wouldn't happen well
when I was why I mean so um this comes
down to the idea of what is at work here
is a very pernicious and insidious way
of patrolling the reservation right
within the reservation certain things
are allowed we're all in the reservation
right and the reservation is guarded by
a liberal elite which allows certain
things to be said but certain things are
not allowed to be said
that's why I've cut mine in my book that
the noble liar and the idea behind the
title of that book is this that the BBC
is not a Millian organization motivated
to do us harm on the contrary
it thinks of itself as being a very good
organization motivated by the best of
intentions and it wants to do is all
good and that's why it won't allow us to
talk about certain things which it
doesn't feel a proper to talk about
because they're nasty so for instance
one might say that the BBC has thrown
its protective weight behind the Muslim
community in Britain so anybody who
attempts to critique Islam is almost
instantly labels as an islamaphobe and
the effect of that is to crush all
comment about Islam and to bully those
people who have genuine concerns about
Islam and and and the way that it
operates it's to bully them into silence
that's why you you don't hear those
debates on the BBC there are lots of
other things they won't talk a bit you
know the limitations of feminism
feminism is Russian is pricked up yes we
must talk about feminism excellent tell
me why women are inferior I just like to
say that was racist and Francis is
getting fired tomorrow
[Music]